here was the first problem okay when you
drew your circle
and by the way there are some awful
circles out there guys come on you know
we're doing volumes they're by rotation
you're gonna get round things bring
something you can draw around things
with even if it's just a roll of tape
okay um
you've got your circle like so okay now
when you
drill your hole through it okay the most
common error
i found was that when you drill through
okay so let me let me draw for instance
this is what i'll end up with on the top
and it's symmetrical
so here is the lower part
okay there are many many many of you and
i'm not sure if it's just because you
pressed for time
right said look the big thing's a sphere
the middle thing is a cylinder just do a
sphere mine as a cylinder and you didn't
have to do slices or shells or anything
it was like
awesome question one turn the other way
i'm gonna nail this have lots of time to
spare oh
wait if you have a good diagram
right you have a look at the one that
i've drawn that was sufficiently large
you can see
that thing's not a cylinder right
it's got round the weird bits on the end
which is why
you have to treat this by slicers or by
shells now i don't know about you
instinctively and you can see this on my
diagram
instinctively i go towards slices i
don't know why that is
um most of you did too okay so i'm
rotating around this way
and so you can see over here right
you should clearly draw the annular disc
that you'll end up with
it looks like this
okay i should be able to see that
i think i could count on one hand the
number of people who actually drew the
slice out here
right worked out what the inner radius
was worked out what the
outer radius was and then proceeded from
there okay
so the other tricky thing in here was um
and this this goes part and parcel with
treating it as a cylinder
okay many of you when you are
considering your boundaries
okay because it has a radius the um the
circle
has a radius of four right so this point
over here if it did intercept
would be negative 4. okay
however the boundaries are not from
negative 4
to 4 right and again you can see this on
a good diagram
you're only going from this in a bit
like you're slicing off that bumpy part
okay and the bunker up on this side as
well right so you're actually not going
all the way from negative four to
four you're going this awkward distance
right so you had to use pythagoras to
work that out
do you know what this is because it's
the radius right you know what this
is because you know what the diameter of
the drilled hole is
and so from that you can work out this
length and you can see it on my diagram
i think it's three or two
three or two two three sorry backwards
okay there you go so in fact because
there was some work there
my first mark was on the boundary okay
my second mark is four
you do all of this stuff right i think
one of you did it by shells which was
fine
well done because i think you actually
got it right or two two of you well okay
fine
um i'm doing it by slices so i've got
delta x you would have delta y
right um you do all of your summation
blah blah blah
first mark was for the boundaries from x
equals minus two three to two root three
right the second mark was for getting to
the integral
right so you've got to do a bit of
working and then you get to here
take out your constant
and then this is your integral
okay first mark
second mark here for your integral the
third mark
was for after you actually integrate
then you evaluate
you need to have a line like this
okay so again like i said the
integration and the evaluation they
really matter
this is volumes right it's critical that
you get this point in
because i didn't give you a final answer
right therefore the last mark was 4
getting to 32
3 and i think because they actually
provided units in the question
centimeters cubed
so you'd slap that onto your final line
one two three four there are the
critical marks
okay